[Música]
gracias para continuar con france 24 y
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con nos acompaña
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia voto gracias por estar con
nosotros nuevamente y cuéntenos que se
conoce de la muerte de este voluntario
que participaba en las pruebas de la
vacuna de doctor ya esta zénica en
brasil se conoce ya si el hombre había
recibido la vacuna como tal que estaba
por supuesto en estudios o un placebo
lo que conocemos actualmente liliana es
que la persona recibió clase o que
significa placer que no recibe la vacuna
sino un similar digamos lo para
compararlo con la vacuna esta persona es
un hombre joven de 28 años que es un
médico y lamentablemente él falleció a
lo que sí
al parecer por complicaciones de la cob
y eso que significa que no recibió la
vacuna eso es el punto clave en este
momento doctor pero socava esto de
alguna manera la confianza que se tiene
en esta vacuna que es una de las más
avanzadas hasta la fecha y que podemos
decirle a la ciudadanía para que confíe
en los estudios que se están realizando
por parte de las farmacéuticas en el
desarrollo de estas vacunas
casualmente estas informaciones es lo
que nos da la seguridad de las vacas
esto no es una competencia contra el
tiempo de por si se están desarrollando
muy rápido pero aquí lo importante es
hacer la segunda forma segura cada uno
de estos que se llaman eventos adversos
deben ser evaluados por comités
independientes y dicen es segura la
vacuna esto no tiene una complicación
directa por la vacunación sigan adelante
en los estudios todas estas
informaciones los que nos reafirman en
la confianza de que las cosas se están
haciendo bien éticamente y correctamente
doctor cuáles son los riesgos para una
persona que participa en el testeo de
una vacuna como la algo y 19 se conocen
casos de personas con secuelas graves
hasta la fecha
se han conocido algunas informaciones
sin embargo los de sal en las próximas
semanas
básicamente el riesgo es uno no recibir
la vacuna como recibir un placebo y
asumir que está vacunado entonces es
importante y se advierte a cada uno de
los voluntarios que puede recibir la
vacuna o el placebo y por eso se decía
siempre lo segundo es que generalmente
las vacunas producen en el sitio local
después dolor inflamación pesos usuario
en cada una de las vacunas y los
reportes severos de efectos adversos
siempre son analizados por grupos
independientes de los investigadores si
ven que están relacionados con la vacuna
se suspende el estudio si no le dan
adelante para que se continúe con la
evaluación de la vacunación justamente
como usted lo menciona se confirmó que
las pruebas van a continuar a pesar de
este suceso que sigue en la fase de
prueba entonces
estamos en la fase 3 de seis vacunas
esta es una de ellas es la última fase
antes de la aprobación en este momento
se está haciendo un reclutamiento masivo
entre 30.000 a 60.000 voluntarios se
están evaluando en estas 1020 semanas
mirando la seguridad de la vacuna ya se
probó la eficacia ahora se está
evaluando en la seguridad de la vacuna
tal vez en un par de semanas de segunda
semana tercera semana de noviembre ya
están en los resultados y se somete a la
aprobación así que tenemos esperanza de
que la vacuna más o menos en un mes mes
y medio ya tengamos información
suficiente sobre su eficacia y seguridad
doctor se nos habla de un reclutamiento
masivo donde se están probando estas
vacunas las diferentes existen en grupos
grandes de personas hablaba hablado
usted de una cifra de 30.000 más o menos
hasta el momento que se sabe de efectos
secundarios de efectos también pues
positivos dado el caso en las vacunas en
estudio sobre la gente que se ha
ofrecido ya a participar voluntariamente
las informaciones son parciales liliana
porque hay que esperar recaudar toda la
información para casualmente ni generar
falsas expectativas ni falsas
desesperanzas tenemos que ser un poco
pacientes para poder entenderlo los
exámenes y las evaluaciones terminan en
un par de semanas y segunda tercera
semana de noviembre ya tendremos como
una información oficial de la mayoría de
vacunas en la fase 3 y sabremos cuánto
es su eficacia qué efectos adversos tuvo
cuáles no lo estuvo etcétera etcétera
pues agradecemos al doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia por
estar en 5 minutos con aquí en plan 24 y
también por la información que nos acaba
de compartir y ustedes los invitamos a
que sigan conectados con nuestras redes
sociales y nuestra página web france24
puntocom para tener más información útil
en estos tiempos de kohl 19 y ustedes si
pueden cuídense del virus y quédense en
casa nos vemos más adelante
[Música]